Good morning, John. I don't know if you've seen this, but in case you haven't, I wanted to bring it to your attention.
There was a young nerdfighter in Indianapolis, Indiana, who went to get the book that you signed
and she recorded her experience. And she was very excited.
And I also kind of experience the awesome of this video in an unusual way.
First, I wanna say that I have permission of the person who made this video to use this footage.
Second, I want to say that I'm in no way making fun of her.
I'm a little bit in awe of her, actually. I wanted to experience the awesome of nerdfighteria
in a different way, and then I wanted to let you all experience...
the awesome that I experienced through the way that I experienced it,
and that is what is about to be shown to you.
I hope you'll enjoy it. You'll want to turn your speakers down.
Sorry if the camera is shaking, but right now, I'm, like, speeding to try and pick up...
the book that John Green just showed he was signing, that Maureen Johnson
book, and I'm gonna try and get there...
I can't remember,
the alphabet,
I can't remember the alphabet...
Wait,
Oh, my God,
I got it,
Cant believe I got it,
Cant believe I...
Is that really his signature?
It's like J--J, scribble.
J--J, scribble.
J, scribble,
J, scribble...
'Kay, bye.
Thank you very much to Marion for letting me use that. I've obviously changed clothes since I made the video.
And you can subscribe to her channel, right here. Isn't that pretty cool? Yeah?
John, I hope you appreciate how much you are loved. I love you, the nerdfighters love you. We all love you.
I can't imagine anyone having that reaction when going to "Eco Geek".
No, not really.
Nerdfighters, I have it on good authority that you'll see me performing a song about Star Trek in the next week or so.
And, John, I have it on a pretty good authority that I will see you this weekend.
Marion says "Subscribe"!